this realization that everything is code
and code moving on many levels is I
think a further it's more primary than
the perception for example that things
are made of space time matter and energy
that's one level below code the code
codes for space time matter and energy
it's much more like we're in a
simulacrum some kind of machine
environment and in fact I like that idea
because I've always sensed and
psychedelics have always intensified
this intuition in me that the universe
is a puzzle life is a is a problem to be
solved it's a conundrum it's not what it
appears to be there is a there are doors
there are locks and keys there are
levels and if you if you get it right
somehow it will give way to something
extremely unexpected DMT is a perfect
example of that and of course at the
molecular level it literal eise's that
metaphor I mean the DM the DMT is the
molecular key the extraneous object
introduced into the front door of the
synaptic receptor and then you know you
can plunder the palace for five minutes
if the world is the world is towed then
it can be hacked in other words it won't
it needn't stand still in quite the same
way that it stands still in your mind if
you believe in something called the laws
of physics it permits magic because it
says behind the laws of physics is a
deeper level and if you can
that deeper level you can make you can
make changes there at least create a
world where those who aspire to
transcendence are not blocked in the
aspiration and of course it's not it's
not that some of us are these puris
pirates and others the haunters of the
sleazy side of the Internet we each play
all these roles and move in between them
according to taste and mood I mean one
of the great falsities of print is is
the making illegitimate of schizophrenia
I mean we are all just swarms of
personalities the idea that a healthy
person has a unified identity is just a
silly idea it's like believing that
sexual preference comes in only two
flavors or something it's one of those
incredibly weird simplifications that
once made everybody lines up and salutes
no matter how much agony it causes a
individuals nothing lasts if that is not
a cause for Jolie or despair it's a
cause for expanding one's feeling in the
moment if nothing lasts then there's a
conclusion not a feeling to be drawn
from bad observation the conclusion to
be drawn from it is then the felt
presence of the immediate moment must be
what life is for and somebody who could
take that perception and use it that way
could immediately transcend all kinds of
neurotic behavior longings regrets
doubts fears no you just say no the felt
presence is immediate experience
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you